eleven of Florida's major airports are
reopening this morning after her forced
them to close more than 14,000 flights
have been canceled in Florida and the
Caribbean since Emma's impact more than
ten thousand of those were in Florida
alone at hartsfield-jackson airport in
Atlanta the world's busiest airport
1,800 flights have been canceled Kris
Van Cleave is at Miami International
Airport where a limited number of
flights are taking off and landing this
morning
Chris good morning good morning that
first flight has landed here at Miami
International departures will start soon
these are some of the people who will be
among the first to get out of Miami post
Irma now airports in Fort Lauderdale
West Palm Jacksonville Orlando and Tampa
plan on reopening today as well Fort
Myers Airport wasn't damaged by herma
but is still without power
it is hoping to reopen tomorrow several
con courses here at Miami International
suffered water damage during the storm
some ceiling tiles and gate areas fell
down as well to reopen the airlines had
to fly in planes with staff crew and
supplies yesterday the TSA also had to
fly in some employees to make sure it
had enough people to be able to get the
airport checkpoints up and running and
airport crews had to go make sure mi a's
jet fuel supply was not contaminated by
the storm and was still pumping now
flights are not all operating some
flights will be canceled today so check
your flight status before you head to
your airports charlie chris thanks